like so men that are rich are cheating
more apparently and then look at the
stats here because they just have way
more options yeah and by the way it's
not necessarily the men going out there
and like I'm gonna cheat because I'm
rich no they're just attracting way more
female attention and those women that
are cheating with those men they're
complicit in that like the woman wants
that guy knowing what he's at yeah well
I think a lot of guys would have a hard
time in Tiger Woods position where he
comes every day statistically most
faithful man on the planet actually what
you know think about it Tiger Woods
listen listen okay listen so Norm
Macdonald who died last year and I love
normally all the comedian okay he had
this joke you know like Tiger Woods uh
comes home after a golf tournament not
come home comes to a hotel and he's like
hello I'd like a chicken sandwich please
what no I don't want a [__] to end
all [__] I just want a chicken
sandwich because I've spent time with
professional athletes I'm gonna tell you
guys a story so I had a a friend who's a
professional athlete who's a neighbor of
mine
and I'm like I'm not gonna name names
but very famous person like very very
high level athlete everybody knew he was
making a [__] ton of money so I've spent
a lot of time pro athletes
we go to one of his games
won't say the sport we go one of those
games
we're sitting uh in the family section
because I know this guy so he's like
here's some fat you can go into the
family sections me and my wife in the
family section and the family section is
like right at where the action is we're
like literally we could probably high
five if we reach over enough right right
two girls are in the front row I know
who they are but they look good
and they're yelling at him now Imagine
This
hey
we're together you
and us
and he's just like he hears it right so
imagine you're a man okay you go to work
you go to work I don't care what you do
you're gonna count you show up at the
office yeah and two of the hottest 22
year olds you've ever seen show up at
your office where you work hey we want
to double team you today what do you
think what would you do as a man it's
like that's just the life that he lives
I've seen this I've seen this well
that's and that's my opinion on it it's
just like like I feel like as women it's
just like I think a lot of guys would
have a hard time in his position imagine
typing but this guy's not tiger man even
even even a good a good man who doesn't
want a tea if you every day you know
it's like at some point he might but
this office doesn't even like hey we
work together and we had a long
conversation we connected this isn't
that these are these are women showing
up at his work
right dressed provocatively and there
and by the way these are not sixes and
sevens these are some of the hottest
women you'll ever see because they know
that that's how they validate themselves
because that's the guy they want and
they show up at your work and they're
just soliciting you for that like
they're just like hey anything you want
right here and that's every day of his
life and he's traveling 80 of the time
he's married with kids wow and they know
it because he's in the community right
right and I don't know if this guy ever
took it up like I've never seen him take
it up because but it's just part of his
everyday routine we're like you can't
even like walk to work without some
check rack I've I've had another one I
golf with the captain of my of my hockey
team uh NHL team one time we golf
together like I knew him from you know
just being a client he's like come golf
with me sure just me and him so I spend
you know I I'm terrible at all but 18
holes with the captain of the team I'll
say yes every time a girl recognize him
she ran over for a selfie and an
autograph she's like oh you can save my
Instagram you know like women at that
level when they see a guy like that it
was crazy for me because I've never been
treated by women like that just just
transparently I didn't know that was a
thing right the way that women treat
those guys like it's like the way that
guys treat the most beautiful woman they
ever see like they're getting DMS these
guys they're getting approached on the
street like it's just crazy well I think
that's where like a lot of times the red
pill and like the trade cons kind of get
into arguments because it's like the red
the tradcon guys will be like well you
should never cheat on your wife and it's
like some of the red pill guys are like
well you've never been in that position
you know and so it's like they'll be
like shaming the the guys that cheat for
like being in a position they've never
been in I've talked I've talked to my
wife about this you know and I'm really
open with my wife like we have we have
you know we've been married 10 years
right and we've been together for 13
years so we have four kids and I'm like
I'd say like I don't know what how I
would react to that it's like I would
like to believe the best of myself like
I would like to believe that I would
hold myself the highest standard and
certainly like I realize there's always
opportunities but like I've never had
like two cheerleaders dressed like
scandily and beautifully like walk up to
me and be like hey what are you doing
right now let's go back to our hotel I'd
just be like uh like I don't know what
my brain would do like I would like to
believe the highest of myself I really
would and I'd like to say hey I'm gonna
I'm gonna make the right decision but
I'm not tempted at that level do you
know what I mean like when things are
transpiring and escalating I can catch
on pretty quickly like oh she's giving
me the eye this isn't that this is
different
yeah and I think I think that's where
like sometimes like they they'll get
into like disagreements I don't know and
the one thing that's interesting you
said on the show how you were talking
about how you should sleep around as a
guy when you're single when you're
single yes you should yeah and I because
I think a lot of times the Chad counts
will come in and be like you know you
shouldn't contribute to the problem you
you kind of seem like a mix a bit uh
well I'm just I'm a realist yeah and
that's like and that's what the red pill
guys are saying it's like well we're
just responding to the women like we
wanted we wanted a girl at a 20 year old
virgin but they don't they don't really
exist I don't I don't believe that's
necessarily true I think that what you
said yesterday struck me as you said you
have to be a little bit more selfish I
agree with that that's the Ein Rand you
know the randian philosophy which is
like if you act in your own
self-interest it's up to everybody else
to act in their own self-interest and at
least the best outcome well I'm a pretty
hardcore capitalist in that sense I do
believe you should act in your
self-interest and I believe others
should too as a man when I'm 23 24 and
I'm single it is in my interest to to
sleep with as many beautiful women as I
possibly can that is 100 of my interest
and it's 100 in the women's interest to
get a commitment from the best guy they
can possibly get and that's exactly I
should be trying to do yeah and if I'm
unable and here here's how you destroy
that argument by the way if I'm unable
to sleep with any women it's not the
women's fault right and if a woman is
not able to get a man to commit it's not
the man's fault because we have to be
equal here you want equality there's
equality people are like well as a man
you should do this it's like well it's
like well how do you feel about these
guys that are like really angry at women
we hate them wasn't it your fault you're
not sleeping with them no it's like
they're not attractive okay then isn't
it then likewise your fault that you
can't get a man to commit
um yeah yeah but
and but that's like where sometimes I
feel like
like I feel like a lot of times the way
that men act is in response to the women
because like if we required marriage
before sex like then men would wait like
they would marry us before that but it's
like it's like I feel like a lot of the
way that men like the Trad cons will
like point at the men and be like you
act like this it's like well the women
started it
the problem is it's not it's not um it's
not men or women that are the problem
it's delusional people yeah it's not men
or women's do like like I don't care how
much you want to argue biology you can
negotiate desire you can't argue biology
like like and people that we had this
girl on the show yesterday right like
she just had this belief of how things
should be right you know and I and I sit
down with with guys in our company that
are young they come in guys and girls
and the first three lessons we have a
three-part video series they watch their
first day at work and the three-part
video series is destroying delusion one
destroying delusion 2 and destroying
delusion 3. and I say my goal for you
when you start working here is to
divorce your delusions right divorce
your delusions from you like I want to
point you to like you're gonna say well
this works this works this works but I'm
going to show you what actually works
okay that's it and some people go
through that and they are thankful what
are the delusions oh there's like
there's like for example uh there's one
let's talk about sales for a second
there's one delusion that like knocking
on doors and selling doesn't work like
oh people don't buy like that anymore
everybody just buys on dinner that's
just like that solution as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible